All right, this is an update on the
fundamentals of active inference where
we've been having a reading group,
textbook group, and I have just 1 minute
ago uploaded open source code to work
through examples of the first three
chapters.
Clone into the active inference
institute  fundamentals repo.
Run   run  sh.
You'll get a text menu that pops up. Hit
W to launch the local interface.
And it will pop you up into this web
browser.
And for each chapter,
there are
images
where all the methods are in the repo.
Chapter one on the hypothesis testing
brain.
Talking about priors, likelihoods,
posteriors.
Chapter two, hidden state estimation.
Looking at how observations and latent
states come together.
Looking at marginals.
Different analytical and heuristic
approaches to posterior estimation.
And where we'll be heading next week is
combining learning and inference. So,
looking at Bayesian linear regression,
combining
learning and inference.
And we will continue to version and
update this repo
collaboratively in the textbook group.
So,
take a look.
Right here in the comments on YouTube or
join the textbook groups if you'd like
to follow along, learn along, contribute
along. Open source.
Thank you.